naija mourad and the Mia as you bashar  will receive the european parliament  sakharov prize for freedom of thought  after escaping the clutches of the  islamic state in iraq they become  symbols of the Yazidi struggle  punctuality higher quality services and  more choice overall for rail transport  the railway reformed submitted to the  plenary should open up national markets  to all European rail operators mep sr to  vote on a ban against deep sea fishing  below 800 meters in the northeast  atlantic new forms of fishing like  bottom trawling are endangering fish  stocks and the local ecosystem the  Parliament Commission and Council are to  sign a common agenda with specific  priorities for 2017 jobs growth and  investment security migration energy and  a digital single market